wir haben es gerade schon einmal gesagt
man muss immer wieder betonen es ist ein
gefühl ist wie hier in deutschland
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen können
gerade dass man sich hinein seiner
wohnräume vielleicht sogar einen bunker
zurückziehen muss aus dieser angst
kannst du uns etwas mehr erklären wie
genau das abläuft es sind wenige
sekunden wenigen minuten die man zeit
wieso man vorgewarnt wie man vielleicht
auch vorher darauf vorbereitet dass man
genau weiß dass man in diesen
schrecklichen momenten machen muss
es gibt natürlich öffentliche
schutzbunker in der stadt die über
zugänglich sind die wurden heute auch
überall im land geöffnet und personal
eingesetzt
man sagt immer wenn die sirene los geht
hat man 90 sekunden in dieser zeit
stimmte das nicht so ganz die sirene
ging los und also das waren definitiv
weniger als 90 sekunden als ich die
erste explosion gehört habe ich
persönlich würde es jetzt nicht
unbedingt in den nächsten bunker
schaffen mache ich im fünften stock
wohnung ohne aufzug aber ich habe wie
gesagt das glück dass ich eine neuere
wohnung habe wo es eben ein schutzraum
gibt wir haben gut und da bin ich dann
hin gerannt habe noch versucht meine
zwei katzen auch einzuladen aber das ist
ja nicht so leicht nach kurzer zeit und
habe dann dort gewartet und ich muss
dazu sagen dass leben heute in tel aviv
er relativ normal ist es immer schwer
vorstellbar wenn man in deutschland ist
und die nachrichten liest dann aber das
hier heute ganz lange weit weg es wurden
zwar merkte abgesagt und so weiter aber
eine freundin zum beispiel
familienschmuck auf einem markt gekauft
sagte auch der markt ist sich dann gehe
ich halt an den strand also die leute
nehmen das hier alles relativ gelassen
hin dass es ein stück weit auch
normalität
aber das ist dann heute abend doch so
heftig kam von über 130 raketen es die
rede
das ist doch eine drastische
eiskreationen ja da sind die leute
erstmal ihre soweit sie die zeit haben
die noch zu erreichen in die schutzräume
gerannt und dann war es ruhig und dann
ging aber auch mehrmals also jedes mal
wenn wir da raus gehen wollte sich zu
setzen gegen die serie wieder los das
waren bestimmt
ich habe jetzt nicht mit e c 345 alarme
und in jedem fall schon mehrere
explosionen bei mir haben wir teilweise
auch die türen gewackelt gut da sitzt
man dann im schutzraum und wartet ab was
passiert jetzt mittlerweile höre ich
wieder ein bisschen
mehr leben auf der auf der straße ein
bisschen musik als nachbar aus also
gerade ist hier ein bisschen ruhe
eingekehrt
also erstmal nach berlin und geht es zum
glück so weit gut
es war allerdings tatsächlich ein großer
schock moment wie muss mit unserem
einjährigen sohn der geschlafen hatten
runter rennen umso nachbarn haben uns
hingegen um uns zu helfen uns in
wikinger gunka zuweisen dort dass wir
jetzt über eine stunde zusammen wir
haben viele viele raketen gehört und es
war sehr sehr beunruhigend
zwei minuten zwei gehminuten von mir ist
ein humus laden getroffen wurden ein
wohnhaus die straße runter menschen sind
verletzt
also ist es eine sehr heftige situation
auf jeden fall aviv auf das ganze land
und die worte von benjamin netanyahu
die sind natürlich auf der einen seite
gut weil nicht nur raketen sind geflogen
im ganzen land stehen bus in flammen es
gab eine schießerei aus einem auto
heraus in der schäfer hier im süden also
es gibt wirklich krieg auf den straßen
was sehr angsteinflößend ist auf der
anderen seite macht es auch angst denn
zum beispiel kollegen meines mannes kann
jetzt schon nicht mehr zur arbeit kommen
weil sich von der armee eingezogen
werden
und ja wir steuern wahrscheinlich doch
oft einen etwas längeren krieg zu was
auf beiden seiten viele leben kosten
wird
sarah was glaubst du denn ganz
persönlich was führt in den nächsten
stunden passieren in israel wie wird es
weitergehen kommt diese bodenoffensive
oder bleibt es am ende bei luftschlägen
also wir haben jetzt den bunker
verlassen aber alle sind sich ziemlich
sicher dass wahrscheinlich in der nacht
noch weitere angriffe folgen werden und
sollte es die nächsten tage so weiter
gehen hier die angriffe auf tel aviv und
auf israel ab lang war heute unter sehr
starken beschuss es gab opfer dann
rechtlich auch mit einer bodenhaftung
sei eine frage noch in die toskana
gesagt ihr habt dem bunker verlassen wir
haben bereits von anderen kollegen
gehört sie hat musik schon wieder gehört
auf den straßen tel aviv ist etwas mehr
los und bereits tagsüber waren die
menschen noch nicht ganz sicher wie
ernst die lage für sie in tel aviv
vielleicht
man kann sie wollten einen strand gehen
wie ist es denn wenn man jetzt in dieser
konstanten bedrohung ist vor allem in
tel aviv der stadt die also so wichtig
für israelis über den flughafen
gesprochen
wie ernst hast du deine familie die
situation beispielsweise heute im laufe
des seit gestern bereits genommen die
muss man sich falls jemand der in dieser
zone ersetzt lebt
das ist perfekt zusammengefasst ist es
diese konstante wird büro wie einfach
die ganze zeit auf der schulter sitzt
und das leben geht hier sehr normal
weiter aber man hat buck gegen alarme
die minütlich auf dem handy losgehen und
ich habe heute so viele gekommen als der
aus tel aviv 1 kam habe ich gar nicht
gebucht weil ich dachte natürlich nicht
dass es unbedingt jetzt passiert und
dann habe ich auch schon die sirene
gehört also diese konstante bedrohung
ist könnt ihr gleich was passieren hat
man auf jeden fall aber tel aviv und
generell israelis versuchen einfach sehr
tapfer und sehr positiv in dieser
situation zu bleiben und das leben ganz
normal zu gestalten
sarah noch eine frage noch einmal
persönlich da geht also der raketenalarm
los und wir haben es ja heute mehrfach
gesehen einige raketen sind auch
eingeschlagen beschreibt uns einmal dann
fängt man an mit schwiegereltern mit
eltern whatsapp hin und her zu schicken
mit freunden man versichert sich
gegenseitig dass alles okay ist wie
läuft das wie lief das bei dir heute die
schwiegermutter hat angerufen hat sich
große sorgen gemacht der zither und oft
mit drauf saß natürlich nachrichten aus
deutschland und freunden familie die
sich große sorgen machten
man fragt nach bei anderen freunden man
sieht plötzlich die bilder von den
raketen über meer und gleichzeitig hört
man natürlich auch die einschläge die
manchmal einfach sehr sehr nahe sind und
ja man hofft dass es bald vorbei ist und
ansonsten die israelis die wird uns
jetzt im bunker saß nach unten
angefangen witze zu erzählen um sich so
ein bisschen abzulenken und auch andere
israel ihnen die schon seit 60 jahren
diesem land leben sagen ist ja immer
noch angst immer noch angst und
gleichzeitig witze max hat immer wieder
angesprochen der schnaps der dann
irgendwie das letzte mittel ist vielen
dank zara für den moment und wir sind
froh dass zuerst mit deiner familie aus
diesen schutz punkten also raus contest
wir werden den kontakt zu die weiter
halten alles gute an dich und deine
familie für den moment mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bet schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren